for people who don't know you're the
you're like the it trainer in basketball
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean i
get i guess it's you know
as you know when you're in it you don't
think that but for sure
yeah i think um what some people don't
understand is like
if you're lebron if you're mellow
because i always remember seeing mello
was in with you
heavy when he wasn't like back in the
league yeah you know
um and you have you know especially if
you're on a nba roster right
like there's coaches on those rosters
you were one of them right
um why go to you yeah
i mean that's that's a good question um
you know i study the game i just
i know the game and i know how to
understand people i
i know what motivates james and i know
what motivates mello
and you know you need to figure that out
otherwise they're not going to talk to
you you could you could try to coach
them it's going to go in one ear out the
other
so you need to build a relationship with
them you need to study the game
and uh you know at this point now i have
like such a big name
within basketball uh i can almost like
work with who i want which is like a
super blessing
um i try and like super thankful because
just three years ago
i was hoping i could get just three guys
a day type stuff so
life's really changed it's uh and then
you know
i was the first train ever to be in nba
2k so i have my own character yep yep
first trainer
sneaker deal just doing things that
trainers have never done just trying to
like inspire kids that
if you don't make the nba you could be
like me